let's see who else we can talk to how
about mark from framingham mark from
framingham you're on the air
hi uh can you hear me yes i can mark
hi um you recently expressed a wariness
about blanket student debt cancellation
and i was just wondering what your
reasons for that are
yeah uh so i i've kind of outlined it
before but i'm glad to sort of do it
again
i think that there should be some debt
cancellation and i'm sort of open to
hearing different ideas about what level
of debt cancellation that should be
i think the problem with just a blanket
debt cancellation for everybody period
is that it is going to do a couple
different things that i don't think are
particularly good
one is uh it there should be some
element of it being
need based and need based i would define
it probably very differently
than than uh some others and my
threshold for what is need based would
would be
significant a lot of people would fall
under that but i don't see a reason to
just go in and cancel
all the debt of everybody who went to
really expensive schools because that's
what they chose to do they could have
gone to a cheaper school they could
afford to go to a more expensive school
took on some debt because that's where
they wanted to go could have ended up
without debt at a cheaper school
and we're just going to say here just
take take all the money
and pay it off i also think that there's
people who have debt
forgiveness programs based on the fields
that they are in
if they work a certain amount of time in
a certain underserved area or whatever
the case may be so we're sort of saying
like let's throw even more money at a
problem that already has
a path to having some degree or even
full debt forgiveness
there and it it doesn't seem to me
to make sense to say everyone's student
debt
period is forgiven i want it to be
slightly more targeted than that
i want it to be more than 10 grand but i
don't think it's logical to say
just pay off everybody's debt period
i've not seen a good argument as to why
we would do that
you are still to there should be some
responsibility like listen
it's beyond your control that some
schools now cost 70k
that's insane the reason schools cost
70k
is because it's so easy to get student
loans so the school knows hey we'll go
from 65 to 70k
because it's easy to get student loans
we'll get the money then it'll be their
problem to figure out figure out how to
pay it off like
that's why i want some student loan debt
forgiveness
but to say full total and complete just
doesn't really make sense to me
economically culturally i've not seen a
good argument for it
okay would you mind if i maybe shared a
bit of my perspective on sure yeah no
please please
um so the way i see it is a lot of
people talk about how
people who hold a lot of student debt
tend to be on average higher income
because
college graduates on average on in the
aggregate make more money
um but the way i see it is that higher
income at some point
doesn't necessarily mean that much if
you also have more debt for instance
medical school debt on average on top of
undergraduate
um is 250k for law school it's 150k
and it's kind of like if i run a
business and i want to expand
i may have increased revenues but i also
have increased costs
yeah and in fact this has been studied
and while there is an
income premium to college degrees the
net worth premium
is significantly smaller because you
make more money but you have more debt
debt cancels out some of the more money
you have
so yes you're absolutely right the other
thing i would point out is a lot of
college graduates
just because they have to go where the
jobs are they live in high cost of
living areas so you know a hundred grand
um uh in new york city according to cnn
money is equivalent to 40k in houston
so it's so it might sound a lot on paper
but day to day it's not really that
effect um
so um and personally for me i
tend to lean more towards maybe helping
too many people or otherwise helping
people who maybe don't need that help
rather than risk not helping people who
do need that
totally agree with you that's my view
with all of these social welfare
programs that
you will always be able to find someone
who got a benefit
that you could argue didn't really
deserve it and i want the line to be
where there's a few people getting it
that don't deserve it as long as
everybody that does
is getting it and so for example i'm
very open to the idea of
there's a set amount of debt
cancellation
plus a multiplier based on some
combination of what is your income
and where do you live and cost of like
i'm totally up for that
it doesn't make sense to me to just say
we're canceling
everybody's debt regardless of how much
it is regardless of how much you make
regard
regardless of where you live how long
ago you uh
uh obtained the debt how much you know
all this i'm not there
but i'm definitely at let's let's we've
got to do more than 10k
okay um yeah i definitely understand
where you're coming from i had um
one last question though sure uh you've
had people such as steve keane
and stephanie kelton as well as dean
baker on yes these are people who are
very critical of the economic consensus
and i think you've expressed why we
should be skeptical
of a lot of mainstream economics however
i also think that especially with covet
and climate change
we should listen to expert consensus on
those
in those areas so is that inconsistent
on my part to be
skeptical of the economics profession
but also be trusting of the consensus
in the natural sciences no i don't think
so i don't think so and many
check out my interview with israeli
economist ariel rubinstein who recently
explained
economics is a study of what economists
believe
it's not like for example rocket science
climate science immunology
uh so no i i think it's perfectly
reasonable
to look at economic thinking in a
different way than we look at for
example
uh vaccine vaccine science i think
you're right to look at them as two
different things
okay yeah um it's also worth noting that
like um
um i was listening to what you said
earlier about cancer culture it's also
worth noting
because a lot of conservatives say like
oh universities are are left-leaning
but a lot of billionaires donate a lot
of money to universities
with the expectation that they hire
intellectuals
who will for lack of a better term serve
as mouthpieces for them like koch
brother
like the koch brothers donates a lot of
money to mit yeah
mit then becomes reluctant to hire
left-leaning economists
um so yeah it was great to talk to you
again i really appreciate
uh you taking my call um because i i
really appreciate speaking with you
all right thanks very much great to hear
from you that is going to do it for
calls today
i apologize to everybody i wasn't able
to get to but we will try it again and
we'll take a quick break and be back
after this
one of our sponsors is vincero watches
giving you 15
off a high quality wrist watch is the
perfect way
to elevate your style own at least one
watch
that makes you feel great when you put
it on you can often see me wearing
my ventura watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six
thousand five star reviews and they
stand behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy and
five-year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store
and free shipping at davidpakman.com
watch use the coupon code pacman